hi everyone
um today I want to present to you the
The Vault stack modern and sustainable
analytics stack and before I start
um just a little bit about my background
so my name is Florian I'm head of data
science at innovix I'm a mathematician
by profession I'm interested in yeah
everything analytics personalization
recommendation
also modern data warehousing and have
been using python for about 12 years so
basically all my professional life and
I'm also an open source contributor and
one of the tools you might know like Pi
scaffold for setting up python projects
so what do we do with innovex
um the employer I work for we are an
innovation and I.T driven project house
and we focus on digital Transformations
so we help you to build all kinds of
cool products cool solutions from
infrastructure to back-end front-end
development and of course also analytics
data science and data engineering so
that's the part where I work
so let's get started and before we
tackle the white stack a few definitions
first right I'm a mathematician so
definitions first
um
I want to talk about the differences
between a data warehouse a data Lake and
what ETL and elt actually means so just
as a recap so a data lake is a term that
was like introduced almost 10 years ago
many of you if you are data scientists
data Engineers have worked with it
already I guess the data structure is
quite raw to kind of pump in from all
kinds of data sources everything into a
data Lake the purpose of the data so
what you want to use with it might not
even be determined at that point and
yeah if you're a data scientist data
engineer then you most likely have
worked a lot with data lakes in the past
and it's highly accessible quickly to
update so there's no schemas and so on
you put everything in there you just
need to make sure that it doesn't become
a data swamp over time then there's a
traditional data warehouses and the
traditionally their warehouses the data
is really processed is highly structured
it's currently in induced and mostly
business professionals use it and it's
more complicated and costly to to make
changes because it's highly integrated
so this is for the traditional data
warehouses so now how to get data into a
data warehouse this is where you
normally would do the etls or the
extract Transformer load so on the left
hand side we see all kinds of data
sources so you extract the data into
maybe some some data Lake into a staging
area where you would do all kinds of
Transformations joining the data
filtering doing data cleansing maybe
even applying some machine learning
models to enrich the data and then after
the transformation you would load it
into a data warehouse where it's then
easily access accessible for
some some analytics and visualization
dashboarding
so now with ETL elt so extract law
transform you basically have you reduced
this one step in between this one step
who needed a different processing engine
like spark so you completely get rid of
this you directly extract and load your
data into the data warehouse into a
modern data warehouse that has those
capabilities like Snowflake and do the
Transformations directly in the in the
warehouse so this um like
reduces drastically the whole complexity
so you only have like one processing
engine within your data warehouse it's
more integrated and this gives you also
then faster access to new incoming data
so this is um then elt and there are two
big players in the field of um of the
data business usually all have heard of
data bricks and and Snowflake and data
breaks with the really well-known spark
technology spark processing engine
started off offering solutions for data
Lakes back then and those data Lakes are
yeah the ones we use mostly for for ETL
pipelines so you could say that
databricks has more like a
ETL background so on the other hand we
have a snowflake snowflake has a data
warehouse
background but in a much more modern and
advanced way so that it has the
capabilities to do elt
and over the years actually the the
solutions of both of both providers
um converged so nowadays they share many
features data breaks went more and
became also Warehouse in certain sense
so they call it a lake house snowflake
offers the data cloud and also has many
of the features you would normally
um you would normally expect from a from
a data lake so if you see this
unification and still today the the
snowflake is quite ahead in this race as
they are offering a more modern and more
unified approach to Modern data
warehousing and elt and
[Music]
now I think we have set the stage to end
at a valve stack
so in this Vault stack is basically a
combination of tools that fit nicely
together and make use of elt in
combination with the modern data
warehouse that allows elt
and for all of you who don't know any
Germans about actually just means Forest
in German and it's composed of the four
letters so
um the the W just stands for modern
Warehouse where you could use a
snowflake but also Google bigquery or
data breaks then we have air byte air
byte is a tool that allows you to easily
ingest data from hundreds of data
sources into a modern data warehouse and
it's really easy to use I'm going to
show this and then we have a light dash
light Dash is a self-service bi tool
that is a bit like like looker so you
can easily run ad-hoc queries and do
your charts dashboarding and so on and
everything is kind of tied together by
DPT the data build tool and if you don't
know DBT and have any kind of SQL
scripts that you might be running with
airflow somehow then definitely take a
look into DPT it's uh it's more and more
like adapted from from many companies
it's um
an easy tool to do the Transformations
basically so it brings all the software
engineering best practices to your to
your SQL script by giving them a nice
structure you have reviewed you you
reproducibility you kind of you also
have modularity that you can reuse parts
of your SQL queries easily everything is
version controlled nicely you have
documentation of your columns you have
data lineage you have a nice
visualization so DBT is a really a
must-have and check it out check it out
if you haven't yet used it and yeah the
valve stack basically is the combination
of those four Technologies and as I said
you can run it on on different
um
on different warehouses so like Google
bigquery a fully managed Enterprise data
warehouse only available on on Google
Cloud as you know and there's a DBT plug
in that allows you to
um yeah to interface with bigquery and
also do
udfs with pyth spark then using a data
proc cluster
it's also possible with data bricks with
the SQL warehouses as computation nodes
as databricks is also or is available on
all major Cloud providers and there's
also a DPT plugin to make this possible
and of course if you do anything with
python then it will use in the end Pi
Spark
the coolest approach actually is to use
snowflake as a modern data warehouse
so um as it comes with all the the nice
features of snowflake like all the
governance really easy to use near cro
maintenance and also like spinning up
and down your your warehouses so your
computational nodes in different sizes
in less than a second and so on so it
brings all this and it also runs on all
major Cloud providers has tons of great
documentations except especially those
quick start guides and yeah it's the
easiest to use and full featured option
to get started with the valve stack so
how does this like stack that I
described now look like again in in the
elt kind of fashion so here's the
overview again on the left hand side
let's say we have some data sources then
the e and l part extract and Lord part
are taken over by air byte
so really easy to just put all your data
done in the modern data warehouse which
as I'm going to show later it's going to
be Snowflake and then you use DPT for
all the Transformations using SQL but
also and this is uh like it's newer
feature that came out in the last six
months by DBT that you can also do those
transformations in a combination with
python and there
in implicitly snowpark is used I don't
know if you also attended the talk in
the morning by Michael about large-scale
feature engineering and data science
with snow park and python where he
explained how to use a snow park
directly and here in this case it's
internally instrumented
using DBT
and this allows you to to do it in a in
a really
um yeah in a unified way together with
with SQL and then in the end we can use
slide Dash to to visualize and do ad hoc
queries on whatever we have done
so just to to Showcase this I
made a little tutorial this tutorial can
be found under trustworldstec put org
which is basically only a redirect to a
GitHub GitHub repository that has a huge
readme on how to download and install
all those tools which are all open
source so DPT is open source air by this
open source and also light ashes open
source but of course there's also
managed services available and If you if
you try it out you can install it and
it's basically a DBT project repository
and also the links to the data you're
gonna need so I'm gonna go quickly over
it speed will be quite brisk so
um yeah but rest assured that you can
find all the details in the tutorial
so and speed is actually quite a nice
keyboard because the use case in the
data I'm going to use in this tutorial
is is Formula One data and
in the tutorial the data is just used
and uploaded into snowflake then DBT is
used to run some basic analysis
basically a lot of SQL is used but also
more machine learning
use cases like what if I wanted to
predict the future positions of certain
drivers in future races and in the end
the results can then be be visualized
and this is kind of a typical use case
that you first kind of ingest your data
you have basic analysis you have more
advanced analysis so it can also be
applied to to many other use cases so to
get a rough overview of the data
we it's not overly complex we typically
have
um also here Dimension tables like the
driver Michelle Schumacher Sebastian
fellow I don't know secrets
um like like Silverstone Monaco we have
the constructors like favari and and
certain races like corn please in
certain uh in certain countries and fact
tables like the lap times in those races
by certain drivers the pit stops and and
results and yeah and in in the tutorial
you can play around with it and all the
setups so if you use a snowflake as a
warehouse to activate also python to
have the possibility
to do the machine learning part all you
have to do is to activate the Anaconda
packages so this is a preview feature
but in in public preview and create a
warehouse which is just a computation
node in in Snowflake speak so that DPT
can use a day or can use it later and
that's already it so the the setup is
really really simple then
interesting the data with air byte is
also really really simple so air byte if
you have installed it if you run it you
basically use the screenshot you have a
connection and I set up like you can
just say Okay as a source you take the
the file that you want to upload like a
CSV file you have the destination
snowflake in our case we we manually
gonna
um we we manually gonna trigger it in
any and then you can just launch it and
have have as many connections as you
want in in Practical use cases you would
of course rather have as a source other
databases as three buckets Kafka you but
you can also have things like Twitter
and Trello so Airbus at that point
really flexible and also works closely
with DBT so even that point you could
already Define some additional
Transformations that are directly run in
the beginning
now I'm going to to DPT and
to install DBT together with snowflake
again all you need are a few additional
extensions like for snowflake then snow
park that is the the data frame I API
that is like like Pi spark then
we have the snowflake connector and then
you configure everything in in the
profiles yamo
so I'm now going to skip the whole SQL
part because this is uh pycon rights if
you want to see some some python code so
maybe for all of those who don't know
DBT so DBT works in the way that it says
a model is a kind of a view or table so
every select SQL statement that does
something that is somehow materialized
in a view or in a table is called a
model and with now the possibility you
also have python models this is why this
function is called a model so it does
not mean that it has to be some machine
learning model So to avoid this
confusion and what we do here so this is
the the function basically trains a
model to
train on some features what the future
position of of a race car could be and
we can in TPT context
Define the packages we're going to need
so here python scikit learn and panders
how it's going to be materialized then
we create a model stage so model stage
is just some some blob storage in in
Snowflake where we can later save our
our model then we reference another
table or in a DPT table so the train
test data set so this is something not
shown here but in the in the whole
tutorials this was done using using SQL
within DPT so you reference this table
and what you get back is in this case a
snowpark data frame so at that point we
are now in in snow park but since we
want to apply directly scikit-learn and
the data is not that huge so what we do
is we we make it a pandas data frame we
use a trained test split from Psychic
learn a really really simple model
because that's not the point here
logistic regression we fit on on train
and
um we save the model in the stage
so the main takeaway here is that it's
really simple to combine DBT with python
and leveraging snow park and
snowflake to to make use of it
so how does the inference look like
again we have another model so because
we're going to do the inference and save
the results in a new table so we again
um Define the packages we're going to
need for this function we load the model
from the stage we Define a user-defined
function it does a prediction given a
data frame in this case only with two
columns let's say I only have two
features for the Simplicity of it and
returns then a new column with the with
the actual results what we think what
kind of position the drivers gonna have
here we predict and return it so it's
really simple
again and now to apply this UDF we
reference the holdout data set for
prediction
select the feature colon and we have a
snow park data frame and this is looks
like Pi spark syntax but it's actually
like snow park because it's really much
the same the API so we add a new column
predicted and call the UDF on using the
our feature columns and what's no park
now does for us is that it does all the
conversions into pandas and runs this on
the snowpark data frame so that's again
like really really simple for a simple
use case like this and so we see that
DBT
snowpark snowflake can be easily
combined and you have the power of of
python to
um yeah to to use it
and not only SQL so let's go quickly to
the the last one the with with the
visualization with light Dash so
lighters also again highly integrated
into your DBT project it will pull all
the information from your DBT projects
like dimensions and metrics and what are
those so if we now ask a simple
analytics question
um like what are the average lap times
split by year and Company then this is
the metric and this is the dimension and
you would define those directly in code
in your DBT project which is nice
because if the metrics become more
complicated and you talk to a colleague
about the metric they know how the
metric is defined because it's it's in
code the same with the dimensions and
what light Dash like kind of Open Source
local alternative does for you is you
can run auto queries create the charts
and the dashboards so how does this look
like so just to show you how simple
um like the main view looks and the you
have basically those four just described
options and if we now are interested in
the average lap time all we would have
to do on the left hand side we would
select the race the race name and the
year and the metric and we can also
filter like saying yeah I only want the
Italian Grand play and the British
company and we get a chart and here in
most cases the average lap time of the
British one is a bit a little bit longer
maybe because the circuit is longer
and um just to show you it's uh with
light Dash you can easily kind of
provide other like more business
intelligence uh oriented people that
like an easy way to take the metrics and
the dimensions you define to run ad hoc
queries so it's uh
it's quite nice and of course those
charts can then
um also be saved on different dashboards
um here it also took the minimum Pit
Stop durations you can arrange them give
them to your co-workers to your
colleagues and
um yeah it's uh it's it's a really uh
it's actually a really neat way that it
all plays together nicely with your
whole DBT setup
so
um yeah that's already the the end of
the
um yeah of the overview of the tutorial
as I said so
um everything is on GitHub tried out
um it's way longer and yeah maybe one
more thing not all
um not all use cases are purely like
analytics and I visualize something and
run some talk queries quite often you
also have you want something more
interactive and for this you might know
the streamlit library which is a really
nice way to build and share data apps
and also this was just acquired by
um by snowflakes so you could also at
that point use this to build a data app
so
um yeah to conclude this talk I
presented the valve stack so basically
four powerful Technologies combined and
they really work well together so and
dbts in the in the middle of it and this
stack especially if you have if you're
gonna go for elt then this stack is so
flexible that that allows you to do use
cases from simple analytics but also to
full-fledged end-to-end product data
products
and with this
um I want to also say a short thank you
especially to Hope Watson from our
partners at day DBT Labs
um I built the first iteration and used
her python snowball Park GitHub
repository as a starting point also
um Michael and Marco from our partners
at snowflake helped
um with the details of snow park and
those awesome slides are not by me I
wish I could but my colleague Michael
Hoffman helped
so thanks a lot and yeah we are also
having
um a booth out there so if you have more
questions if you want to later talk to
us then just meet us at the snowflake uh
innovax Booth thank you
thank you very much for this beautiful
and interesting presentation two people
ask how do you create such super fancy
slides
yeah you have to ask Michael but uh what
the software keynote it's keynote and uh
yeah yeah okay and another question
aren't the python udfs in DBT connection
to databricks computationally expensive
and slow
no it's basically so I would compare it
um with with the same overhead that you
also have in in pi spark if you in the
UDF I mean since it's
it depends it really depends if you use
pandas then of course there's going to
be some some copying in between between
the the
um the data frames of snow park into
pandas and this is why you should avoid
using pandas in the udfs but if you want
to use scikit-learn you have to at some
point right but for everything else
definitely only use this no Park API and
then in the morning we learned that
there's a snow park ml coming
right now preview so I'd rather use this
so yeah you have to be careful whenever
you use pandas yeah
thank you another one have you
considered using a lightweight open
source alternative for the
transformation layer for example doc TV
if yes what are the reasons you are not
using it
so that b is a database a really nice
and fast database but
it doesn't spring at least as far as I
know I haven't used it all the
capabilities you would want from a
full-fledged data warehouse so
I'm not sure if DBT has any connectors
so that you can directly use it on on on
DAC TP
might be but yeah definitely ductibly I
would say has has other has other use
cases
yeah thank you there are five more
questions maybe you can meet
with Florian
yeah I'm looking forward to it so see
you yeah but thanks a lot
[Applause]